plenty of people are excited for this by
the way this I think has the most
upvotes slash comments of any pairing of
any theologution so if you have a
fraction of the amount of excitement as
I have I'll I'm super happy about that
people are probably when they watch this
live people are like oh my gosh this I
can't believe this is happening Chris
Langan and Bernardo Castro
okay
well
why don't we start just so you know
we'll talk about metaphysics
Consciousness and computation those are
the general themes for today we'll start
with the substrate independence of
Consciousness quote unquote so Lambda
I'm sure you've heard of this computer
or this algorithm or this AI called
Lambda some people claim it's indeed
conscious
why or why not and we'll start with you
Bernardo if you don't mind
um certainly not
um when we when we say something is
conscious uh what we normally mean is
that that something has private
conscious inner life that is separate
from yours your mind and from the rest
of nature so to be conscious is to have
private experience uh private
phenomenality another way to put it
um and I think we have absolutely no
reason to think that a silicon mechanism
has private inner life of its own it is
it in Consciousness absolutely
everything is in Consciousness
everything begins unfolds and ends in in
a field of subjectivity that underlies
all nature in my view so Lambda is in
Consciousness that doesn't mean that it
is conscious
in and of itself I think what nature is
telling us empirically all the time is
that private conscious in their life
correlates with well life metabolism and
protein folding DNA transcription ATP
burning all that good stuff this is a
far from trivial process metabolism it
uniquely separates biology from
everything else in the universe and it
ties all biology together despite the
tremendous differences between say a an
amoeba run a swimming in my toilet and
me we are completely different yet if
you look down a microscope to the
details of metabolism we are identical
we all do protein folding ATP burning
transcription and all that stuff so
nature is screaming to us that what
private conscious inner life looks like
is warm moist biology metabolism
and Lambda is a silicon computer now can
it emulate or simulate a human cognitive
processing very well well I have little
doubt that it does but the simulation of
a phenomenon is not the phenomenon I
mean I can simulate kidney function on
my computer accurately down to the
molecular level and yet my computer will
not pee on my desk because a simulation
of kidney function is not kidney
function so long day simulating human
intelligence that doesn't mean that it
is conscious because a simulation is not
the thing simulated it's a primary
logical mistake that unfortunately has
been rendered seemingly plausible by our
mad culture because it's being bombarded
on you all the time via the media and
Hollywood movies and Netflix series that
it is plausible for silicon machines to
have private conscious in their life of
of their own even though we have
absolutely zero rational and empirical
reason to think that that's the case
Chris what's your opinion on the same
question if you want I can reread the
question
um uh read the question again
I agree with everything that brown has
said
go ahead and read it again for me please
so whether we basically want to know
whether or not Lambda is indeed
conscious why or why not something are
you talking about the Lambda calculus of
the program recently in the news there
is this AI from Google which was much
like a
like a talk like a bot a talk bot yeah
I'll probably explain incorrectly so
Bernardo do you mind explaining what
them does that's it's a chat bot that's
that's what it is yeah and it probably
will pass the Turing test well for what
that means I mean has Bernardo pointed
out the Turing test isn't the end-all
be-all you've still got a machine
simulator even if it stimulates very
very well and convinces you that it's
human nevertheless it is not human so
basically you're asking well the Lambda
calculus is a construct it's a it's a
computer program it's a mathematical
construct which exists in something that
could be likened to the syntax the
accepting syntax of something in
computation Theory that's called
acceptor we've got acceptors and
processors they transduce information
they accept input and output from the
external world then they process it
internally so we're talking about
Consciousness being the internal phase
of that process
and the idea is the
metaphysics as far as metaphysics is
concerned
as far as I'm concerned anyway in my
opinion
metaphysics is about putting the metal
side of your existence in contact with
the physical side we understand the
physical side quite well thanks to the
empirical sciences and the metal side uh
we don't have such a firm grasp on
um Kant you know came up and started
talking about mental categories in terms
of which we perceive phenomenal reality
and that gives us a clue as to what
we're talking about here we are talking
about something very much like accepting
syntax with a computational acceptable
okay the idea of putting those two
things together it requires something
called all we have to do is we
it's a very simple operation we we
basically say that cognition is akin to
a cognitive identity language it allows
us to identify things so it's a language
then we say the physical universe is a
manifold that space time management
which things are happening the idea then
is to connect these two things that
takes a kind of metallic language that
spans both the both of these two object
languages that we have one of which
deals with values coordinate systems and
things like that that's the the manifold
and then you've got the other side which
is qualitative more qualitative more
attributed right that's the metal side
so we're uniting those two things in one
metaphormal language that has to be
quantized in a certain way
and those identity operators that I was
just talking about that are a little bit
like computational acceptors those are
the quantum
okay they're active science
if you look at the linguistic aspect of
what I'm talking about there active
science in the language but they are
also the points of the manifold or the
universe that contains the content to
which you refer with the language
you only
this is a mathematical this is a this is
something that you know I did 30 years
ago and I more or less had my own way of
talking about it let me know if I'm
losing it sure so I have a quick
question and then Bernardo please jump
in if you're unsure or you have
clarifying questions so you said that
there's a mental world and then there's
something like the physical world which
you said is like a manifold well they're
both seeing a metaphormally coupled you
can't if you take a state
it consists of attributes and values for
the attributes you can't take those two
things apart
what I'm saying is they're metaphormally
coupled
all right you can you can deal with pure
attributes but but you can't do that
without instances or at any rate a
cognitive identity operator to actually
perform the metal functions involved
right
so there's no way and as far as the
values are concerned you take a an
object without attributes that's an
oxymoron okay there is no object that is
totally without attributes you've pinned
an attribute on it by calling it an
object
okay so you can't take those two things
apart there's simply no way to do it so
this dualism between the mental and
physical sides of reality I say is
nonsense it takes this metaformal
approach in this metaformal metal
language that I'm talking
Bernardo do you have any thoughts on
that
or questions increase jumped into
probably more details of his theory
which I'm not acquainted with so if I
start asking questions now you'll
probably
speak for the next two hours just for me
to understand something I should have
understood by reading a paper which I
haven't read so I'm not going to tax you
with this uh Chris yeah well what I was
trying to to answer more or less was the
idea of what metaphysics is and how
Consciousness relates to metaphysics
okay so what I'm saying is that
metaphysics has to be this metaformal
metal language and Consciousness relates
to it as a distributed property thereof
that that would be your your particular
usage of the word metaphysics or in
metaphysics is a word that has been used
since you know the pre-socratic so
because
there is a sort of a
common common meaning for the word in
philosophy metaphysics that which stands
behind physics or the essence or the
beingness of things as opposed to
appearances and behavior precisely I'm
saying that has to take the form of a
metaphormal metal language
of the metal and physical sides of
reality in other words span between both
of those things building a bridge
between them that's the purpose of
metaphysics and I understand that many
different people have have defined it in
many different ways and the long and
short of it is although I'm you know
respect you know people having their own
ideas about things I don't find that
especially useful you can go and look at
everybody's definition and not come out
with anything very stable that you can
work with
so I settled on a mathematical structure
that I can work with to make sense of
these Concepts these metaphysical
Concepts
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy